[Music]
up next join us for this week's edition
of book notes we'll spend an hour with
author kenneth edelman a former director
of the arms control and disarmament
agency he discusses his book titled the
great universal embrace armed summitry a
skeptic's account
[Music]
ken edelman author of the great
universal embrace
also former arms control agency director
in the reagan administration
what are you doing teaching shakespeare
at georgetown university well i have
found through life that if you want to
understand life there's no better way
than reading shakespeare and then
discussing it with a lot of people
because you have a situation as i
explained in my class last week
where you have a magnifying glass
put on situations so that we can see
them in their clarity and see them in
their full dimension in shakespeare
which we normally in life could skip
over have you done this have you
studied shakespeare for a long time i
never studied shakespeare besides
reading a lot about it and reading the
place i never took a course in english
literature in my life but i've loved
shakespeare for a long time i taught
before i became arms control director i
taught at georgetown and i taught
courses in hamlet and then hamlet and
ruskolnikov which is a comparison of the
heroes of hamlet and crime and
punishment
by dostoyevsky
and
then when i left the government i
decided to go back to it so i did it
last year
teach shakespeare georgetown and then i
teach security studies at johns hopkins
let me ask you in a moment about this
book
before we do that though i want you to
tell us what is
the
united states arms control and
disarmament agency
that is the agency that by law is
supposed to be the principal advisor to
the president on arms control matters
how big is it it's about 250 people what
do those people do they negotiate with
the russians
they do the forward planning
for
our arms control positions
for our verification
they
look at the interrelationship between
various negotiations
we
lobby the hill when necessary to get a
treaty passed we explain all this to the
public
and we advise the president during his
national security council meetings you
were there for how many years almost
five what training did you have before
you got there that
was the best help to you
the best help i guess that i had been in
government some seven or eight years
before then
so i knew how government worked
i had been up with jean kirkpatrick as
her number two at the united nations for
two years
so i understood quite well the
international politics quite aside from
the substance
i had been in the pentagon with
secretary of defense don rumsfeld as his
assistant
in the mid 70s i had written a lot so i
had the practical experience i had the
pentagon experience
i had the academic experience for
writing about it
but
it's like so many things in life
till you do it
you don't really understand how to do it
what do most of those 200 plus people
do for the agency every day
most of them plan out where we're going
to go in arms control what the various
options should be how we could verify it
how the russians would react to it
and really service the arms control
talks that are going on don't forget we
have many talks going on with the
soviets at any one time we have talks on
strategic weapons we have talks during
my day on intermediate nuclear forces
which is the treaty that reagan and
gorbachev signed on the back the week
that i quit the job
finished
feeling that i had
accomplished what i had come to do we
had talks
among 23 countries on conventional arms
that's normal army navy stuff
we had talks among 40 nations on banning
chemical weapons
and so we had a lot of going on and it
always seemed like a three-ring circus
what was your biggest surprise after you
took that job
how much time and attention ronald
reagan and secretary of state george
schultz would give to arms control
time that we never saw we never saw
it seemed amazing to me i joined the
agency in 1983
and as i recall in the book at some
point
i'll bet you that year alone
i had some 10 15 meetings with the
president probably another 20 in the
white house
with the top echelon without the
president
[Music]
that's a lot that's just a big chunk of
his time a big chunk of the top level
time
and attention
and so you know you're dealing with
something awfully important
has the president
former president gotten a bum rap from
both his critics and those in the media
for being
not giving attention to detail
it's a complicated thing i had a hard
time
with ronald reagan in the book
i tremendously admire him
i think that the way he left u.s foreign
policy
and american general was far better in
the way he came
i think that a lot of it is due to his
doing
and if he had left it worse he would
have gotten the blame so why don't we
give him the credit when he left it
better
however at the same time there were some
appalling gaps in his knowledge
he was one of the most uncurious men i
have ever met
he was
used his personality to its fullest
extent
and the relationship with gorbachev was
one
which i watched up close and personal
and had a lot to do with the change of
the relationship between the united
states and the soviet union
i don't know
and don't understand very well having
worked with them for five years
ronald reagan
and i was talking to a very close friend
of his yesterday
who said that's okay
he had been a close friend of his for
some 40 years he didn't know and he
didn't understand ronald reagan there's
a mystery about reagan
that
very much lingers in my mind
and it's one of the perplexing things of
working having worked for him and it's
one of the
unsettled things about the book
because you spent so much time around
him um
what is it that you saw about him that
we never see
that at times when he had to be good he
was very very good
there were gaps in his knowledge
there was a passivity that was legendary
but by god that sunday afternoon in
reikovic
with the wind howling outside the hofty
house
the huffy house supposedly
being
spooked
or haunted as the legend has it in
iceland
and mikhail gore and
000 reporters outside
saying in essence
that ronald reagan could get the nobel
prize he could be a hero if only he
would gut sdi the strategic defense
initiative
his own program to protect america and
mikhail gorbachev
banging away at him like crazy
ronald reagan just said no
he wasn't about
to pander to those guys outside the 7000
press guys or to mikhail gorbachev's
blandishments
and he just wanted a good arms control
agreement was but was not willing to
settle for any
and i saw him up there
sit in the corner of the room and say at
one point geez this isn't preparing for
a summit this is a real summit
and getting very
aggravated about it in a certain sense
because gorbachev was demanding that we
stop all kinds of research to protect
the country kind of research that the
soviets had been doing for years
so it was a kind of a magical moment it
was an impressive moment i don't know
many people
in my life who would have performed so
well
at that moment
nor do i know many people who would sit
in
to me seemingly important meetings
at other times with such passivity
with such indifference
he's a very mysterious man
as is gorbachev and that's one of the
things i hope to do in the book is to
paint portraits of these two men who are
obviously the dominant
men of the 1980s did you take notes
while you were around these men
very sketchy very little i found some
notes that were kind of interesting
after the book was in galleys in fact
where george schultz
describes to me his first impressions of
gorbachev first time he met him which
was at
the previous soviet president's
funeral but that's in the book yeah and
so i took those notes which were
amazingly accurate i mean good credit to
george schultz
other times i did but most of it i
remember you remember things that you
think are very important you remember
magical moments in life
and when you're sitting there at
reykjavik with the president in a little
bubble when you're having lunch with the
president the
morning after he spent his first morning
relatively alone with miquel gorbachev
when you're
waiting with reagan for gorbachev to
appear at the washington summit you
don't forget those things you remember
everything about it
i remember in your book mentioning you
mentioning that
mr gorbachev told mr reagan that he
watched his movies
how much of that
is true and how much how many movies has
he watched
who knows how much of it is true
what is true is that mikhail gorbachev
was unlike any other soviet leader
he knew his guy he knew ronald reagan he
knew the way to get to ronald reagan and
he cared about getting to him on a
personal level
whereas the other soviet leaders
brezhnev jeremienko and dropoff all
these stodgy old
you know dying men
would not have cared they would have
read their papers to gorbachev to reagan
and left it at that
but gorbachev has a tremendous charm
about him
and when he starts out their first
meeting and saying the reagan at the
geneva summit 1985 you know i've watched
this movie i don't know if it was
newt rockne story and compared it to
bedtime for bonzo or whatever it was
and
you could just feel ronald reagan light
up
he talked about what he really loves
which is hollywood how he made the
movies
what who helped him who co-starred all
the mishaps of the movies etc so
god knows if gorbachev ever saw any of
these
oh i do know that gorbachev was smart
enough to click
ronald reagan on
about how he'd seen the movies
a lot of what you write is about the
chemistry between human beings
what's also important what's going to be
the chemistry between george bush and mr
gorbachev
i think it will be
steadier
more boring
more professional
are you concerned about what will come
out of the
bush gorbachev summit no
i was more concerned at first about what
would come out of a reagan
gorbachev summit because i remember
having lunch with the president after
his first meeting with gorbachev
and
having him say oh this guy's very
charming this guy is very good this guy
is very nice
and i got a little worried
and i said mr president you know that
could be for the first morning
but after a while he might get very
ornery he might storm out he might
up his demands he might be extremely
tough this is no
girl scout
leader
and he turned to me says ken i know
exactly what i'll do
if he does that
i said what would you do
and he pulled back his chair
shrugged the shoulders moved his head
he said i'll look at him and say
michael
what about all those nice things you
said to me this morning
just playing the role of a kind of dash
lover
did mikhail gorbachev understand or
speak any english not that i ever
was aware of
what are we seeing when we see the two
men standing alone
during a couple of minutes for photo
opportunity and they're talking to one
another and they're not up and down
what's going on there they have a
translator there i don't see a
translator in the picture no you'll
usually see back of them on the side or
whatever there's somebody there to help
them but once in a while though they'll
go out on the steps of a you know well
then they're just mouthing things
because i don't think that gorbachev
speaks a word and i know that ronald
reagan only has one phrase which is
trust but verify which he says quite
often
why did you choose to come out of your
job in the government and be a writer
and what i mean by that is you write a
column
you're
an editor at washingtonian magazine
i guess i've always loved writing
and in the government i did a lot of
writing a lot of speaking
and
i had such
magical moments
in the government especially in the arms
control era
that i just did want to write about it
in a book plus i wanted to explain for
history
not the gobbly [ __ ] that is arms control
because it's filled with these acronyms
and numbers and you know all the stuff
but what i wanted to
have a first cut of history
on the changed u.s soviet relationship
between 19
in the reagan era
and it's an amazing turnabout we're
going to be living with this
for a very long time what is happening
now in the soviet union
glasnost perestroika with
everybody talking about the end of the
cold war
will be traced back to the reagan
administration particularly between 1983
and 1986
and when you're in the front seat of
history
with a real turn of events
it's important to take a first cut at
that history you have a column that's
published in some 40 newspapers or is
that grown
no i i wish you would grow
after this program it'll grow
what impact has the column had are you
being read
who knows and you get feedback people
like oh you you get feedback but you
don't know what kind of impact
i guess i think of myself as a writer as
kind of johnny appleseed you shove a lot
of seeds over your shoulder and some of
them sprout how much of your life now is
writing
i do the column
i did the book i do a monthly piece for
washingtonian magazine called what i've
learned
i do other outside articles so good bit
i enjoy the teaching enjoy the
shakespeare and the security studies
so it's pretty full you're also vice
president of the institute for
contemporary studies what's that and
what do you do it's a conservative think
tank that was started in the 70s
out in california and basically we
publish books we
help people with books we do books on
education
we do books on
farm problems we do books on foreign
policy and so we have programs that
really
do help people understand public
policies it's going to take a couple of
seconds here but i want to read the
description of why you named this book
the great universal embrace if you'll
give me that moment
this is at the beginning of the book you
say in 1932 the spanish ambassador to
the geneva disarmament conference
told this fable in response to the new
soviet foreign minister
maxime litvinov
grandly proposing quote total and
general disarmament first of all where
did you find this
i found this in an old copy of time
magazine
from the 50s
and did you find this in conjunction
with writing your book or were there no
i was fine i founded you know just
normally doing research in this area and
i thought geez there's an interesting
fable and then i checked it and it was
true
okay you don't have to remember the
spanish ambassador's name it's not in
here it doesn't i don't know that it
matters
manuela or something like that
quote when the animals had gathered the
lion looked at the eagle
and said gravely we must abolish talons
what's a talent
i think it's part of the clause
the elephant looked at the tiger and
said quote we must abolish claws and
and jaws
thus each animal in turn proposed the
abolition of the weapons he did not have
until at last the bear rose up and said
in tones of sweet reasonableness
quote comrades let us abolish everything
everything but the great universal
embrace why'd you use that
well because i thought it was really
perfect
first of all
it has a double play
double meaning with the great universal
embrace being
associated with bearers soviet union
associated with bears
secondly there was a great universal
embrace between reagan and gorbachev
when gorba and reagan hugged them in red
square
it's an amazing moment here is a man who
made his whole career on anti-communism
and bashing the soviets
and saying we'll
really be tough with him
and then he takes the number one soviet
the main communists in the world and
gives them a nice little hug in red
square right under the kremlin walls
that's an amazing moment plus i thought
that it was awfully revealing
because the
[Music]
arms control
effort is always to control someone
else's arms it's never an effort to
control your own arms
we try to control the soviet arms they
do a better job historically of
controlling our arms the other countries
in the world try to try to control
either the soviet american arms or both
everybody wants to help everybody else
and not control themselves
now that you're out of it looking back
how important do you consider
the agency that you ran the united
states arms control and disarmament
agency in the grand scheme of things i
think it was important i'll tell you why
it was the
depository and repository of expertise
on arms control in the government yes
there were some experts in the state
department in the pentagon and they
helped enormously but what
helped
in this historic period was to have a
group of people in this agency who did
nothing else but arms control all day
long
and that means that they had a depth of
understanding and experience
that others
in other departments just lacked in
other words in the state department you
have to worry about central america you
have to worry about the middle east you
have to worry about southern africa you
have to worry about global warming you
have to worry about god knows what
but in the arms control agency you only
had to worry about arms control
at the beginning of your book
in the introduction
you talk about the impact of a speaking
trip in 1984
to something that we have covered a lot
here world affairs council
what is the world affairs council it's a
group of concerned citizens out there in
the world is there a political bent to
it a no
it's pretty fair but when you described
it
you had three different speeches one in
northern california one in orange county
california and one at marina del rey i
believe in los angeles three different
world affairs council meetings and you
spoke to them
why did that have such an important uh
impact on your life and the need to
write this book because it shows the
variety
of views you get in this field
in one in northern california i just got
absolutely reamed out because of the
intensivity or the
uncare that the reagan administration
had shown towards arms control first of
all that was 84 what was the atmosphere
then the atmosphere was there were no
talks going on soviets had walked out in
90 at the end of 1983 and we were being
blamed because the soviets walked out
you flew west to give three speeches
in the period of a day and a half and
you stopped first in northern california
stopped first in northern california and
just got reamed
because of the
antagonism toward the reagan
administration at that time
then i went to orange county and got
criticized because of the
reagan administration
ever wanting to talk to the soviets
because they cheat on arms control they
lie about this and everything like that
it was a very conservative
hard knock group that thought that i and
the reagan administration were soft
then i went to marina del rey where the
people were very nice but very concerned
about the boats and about tennis and
everything else in fact at a dinner
right there
i was sitting with the chairman at the
head table
and after talking about tennis camps and
boats and everything
he turned to me and with a kind of
pained look on his face said well let's
get on with the subject at hand
ambassador edelman everybody knows that
cruise missiles are very hard to verify
this group not that many people cared
about cruise missiles but anyway cruise
missiles are very hard to verify
and we know that slickham sea launch
cruise missiles especially when he says
this he's looking out over the
bay outside with all the thousands of
yachts at marina del rey
so i
talk
you can see that people have this pain
look on their face
that i'm going to go on about these
initials acronyms numbers that
is the mind-bending stuff of arms
control and so i started out and i said
you know
you have sea launch cruise missiles
which are pilotless airplanes they're
small they can fit in people's garage so
small they can fit in the garage
it's nice lady across the table said not
in my garage
you should see my garage it is so filled
with things i have accumulated over the
years that i could pot not possibly get
another thing in my garage
another
woman at the table says try a garage
sale and tell you exactly how to do it
someone else said don't try a garage
sale try a garage sale and a bake sale
combined you'll get more beer so we were
off
in the um never never land of
marina del rey where they were not
seized of these issues a lot of us in
washington always felt that everybody in
the country or if not around the world
was talking about the subjects we were
working on every day
that's not the case
in the acknowledgements that you
give out to friends and colleagues i
want to go through
these people and i want to ask you about
them and why they had such an impact in
your life
you start out by saying to joyce and don
rumsfeld go special thanks for helping
shape my intellectual framework
we started working with don rumsfeld in
the early 1970s after he had left the
congress and became head of the office
of economic opportunity i had the honor
of working with him three times since
then one is secretary of defense
and one other time
he's a very gifted man
he's conservative he's smart
he's determined he's very very kind
this intellectual framework though that
had yeah
really yes and what he really did was to
give we had lived in africa before that
time
uh actually we lived in africa between
the times yeah between the times
that i had worked for rumsfeld in fact i
was a dependent husband in africa i went
there because of my wife i had quit the
government and was getting a phd at the
time and went there as a dependent
husband
the ambassador's wife didn't know what
to do with me i was a first dependent
husband i think in africa she invited me
to her teas into her bouquet clubs into
the wives association and everything
else but anyway when we got back
rumsfeld had a um
view of the world that was conservative
he had good reasons for it good
understanding of it and i learned a lot
from
before i leave don rumsfeld why didn't
he continue to run for president last
time
he couldn't see the money
in it
not for himself but he figured that he
would have to raise about 10 to 12
million dollars which is what you need
to run for president these days
and he could only see his way to get two
and he did not want to go out on a limb
trying to milk people for the other 10
um in such a way that he found very
embarrassing it's a shame because our
system is such that it drives out very
good people
next on your list ellen and don murdock
lynn and dick cheney
shayna and don loetz
don lowett's later when he became one of
america's arms negotiators a role to
which he gave his last full measure of
devotion
we know who lynn and dick cheney are how
much of an impact did they have on you
and where did you first meet him i first
met him in 1970 in oeo the office of
like economic opportunity working with
rumsfeld and with all those people you
mentioned carlucci was there at the time
murdoch was there at the time
uh lewis was there at the time we had a
very special group that was around
rumsfeld
that formed worked together for about 18
months and has
have really remained very good friends
ever since we see the cheneys all the
time we work with dick and lin various
times in our lives we share an
anniversary with them in august we you
know get together for birthdays and
holidays and things like that very very
special people
maria and frank carluccio did not
mention are
basically are all the people on this
list
of similar political philosophy yeah
they're conservative they're uh have a
very good sense of humor they're nice
people
uh they're unpretentious
they're uh good common folks a lot of
them from the middle west or the west
uh not
snobs in any sense where was your where
were you born in chicago i was born in
chicago my wife was born in chicago
cheney's come from wyoming the rum solds
come from chicago
murdoch
come from either chicago or wisconsin
where'd you go to school what did you
what did you study i went to school at
grinnell iowa
which is little college 1100
kids in the middle of the cornfields in
iowa i studied religion and philosophy
and your phd is in then i came to
georgetown i got a masters in
foreign service studies
studying economics and diplomatic
history then i got a phd in political
theory and i did my dissertation in
africa
in zaire
did you find yourself at any time during
your career at the arms agency
uh getting off track with all of your
friends there did they ever call you up
and say some of them were awfully mad
yeah some of them were awfully mad i got
in
i became in 1983 as i say in the book i
became very good friends with dan quayle
and we
shared a lot of times and shared a lot
of experiences in this and at one time
on the inf treaty the intermediate
nuclear force treaty quail who used to
call me every day about something or
other said he was taking a position
on some issue conventional cruise
missiles doesn't matter
and i said i understand your position
but that's just dead wrong
he says no you're wrong so we went at it
he kept talking to me about it he kept
getting
carlucci involved he kept getting kept
weinberger who was then secretary of
defense he got schultz involved with
that he really went on and on and on
and he and i squared off on the this
issue and it went to the president
reagan and um i don't want to say he
decided in my favor but i was very
pleased with the outcome and to this day
when i see quail which is qui
quite frequently um
he'll the only thing that really burns
him is that he lost that fight
you do mention him in the
acknowledgments and i want to talk a
little bit about what you say
not only about him but warren redmond
malcolm wallace
pete wilson
and yourself you talk about a fivesome
getting together talking about arms
control a lot in foreign affairs we
would have lunch every month or so on
capitol hill
with an outsider we would invite henry
kissinger jean kirkpatrick or
others bill crow chairman of joint
chiefs
and brzezinski
messenger whoever
experts in the field and they would we
would talk about the issues and it was a
wonderful group these are senators who
were serious
they were not calibrating
their knowledge to the boat that they
had to do this afternoon or that
afternoon
it was not geared to a press release it
was seriously learning about these
issues and after a few years of that it
was very valuable
one of the statements you make here
jumped out of the page i want to get you
to explain more of it unlike many
and then you bracket the next two words
or most
in a similar position i genuinely liked
in italics my colleagues
and i continue to learn from them as we
stay in steady touch
who are the colleagues you're talking
about
there's a whole group that i dealt with
in the government
i would say that most people when they
leave the government
have had such fights
with people
that they leave on very bad terms or
they don't get together whatever
i never found that i found that i liked
the people i dealt with
i get together with them i talked to
them whether max campbell men whether
richard burke whether richard pearl
whether
the people in the arms control agency i
dealt with
people of the national security council
i dealt with it's a whole you know maybe
15 or 20 people that i dealt quite
regularly with most of which at one
point or another in the five years i
fought with over an issue but tried
always to keep it from being personal
saying we disagree with this issue
but
i don't disagree with you know you
i just disagree with the position but
you do write about two men who had
as you say ongoing constant disagreement
and it was a very difficult thing for
you to deal with and that's cap
weinberger and george schultz how bad
was that situation at times it got bad
i thought both of them brought strengths
and i've had obvious weaknesses to the
job
i think that they graded on each other
in a way that was not becoming to either
of them weren't they both originally
with the same company oh yeah they had
worked together for years they had been
an omb during the nixon administration
together
that weinberger worked for schultz there
schultz worked for weinberger or
something
then after leaving and they never got
along there they had another job
together as i remember
weinberger was secretary of uh
hcw hew or tc federal trade oh it was
called hew then
which is health and education welfare
and chiltz was secretary of the treasury
or director of the omb then when they
left
the ford administration the nixon
administration
they went and both of them went to
bechtel
california-based company construction
company worldwide construction company
schultz was president and cap weinberger
was general counsel so i mean it was
like these two guys who never got along
all that well never respected each other
all that much it kind of
gone along as a package
strange which one did you like the most
from a
policy position standpoint probably from
policy i was closer to
cap weinberger than george schultz about
personally who did you get along with
the most
i got along with both of them personally
pretty well um who did you have did you
have to answer to either one of them
yeah i was more responsible to schultz
than i was to weinberger i was you know
in and out part of the state department
not part of the state department tried
to work close with that i found with
george schultz that even though at times
he was very good especially dealing with
the russians i found him very good
his
knowledge of the subject was not all
that it should have been
all right go back to those and you write
about some of this but go back to those
moments where you saw cap weinberger and
george shelton meeting the president was
there
and there was one time i remember where
george schultz wouldn't take a position
or wouldn't tell the president what his
position was
how often did the country suffer because
these two people were always fired oh i
don't think
that the country suffered much i think
it was painful to watch it was
unpleasant for ronald reagan although he
did nothing to stop it
um
and certainly it must have been
embarrassing to
both schultz and weinberger
it was unbecoming they were
individuals who had served their country
well
overall i think did a fine job
decent people but somehow graded each
other so that they weren't
very good together how would you see it
tell you you mentioned shakespeare
before there's a wonderful
passage
excuse me in anthony and cleopatra
where someone says to anthony every time
you get around caesar
you act poorly
he brings out the worst in you you
every single time
and i think you know that is just a
beautiful
thought and phrase
that there are people with whom we
shine
we feel better we act better
seem better to ourselves and to others
and there are people around whom we just
don't do very well
like anthony didn't do well
any time he was near caesar i think that
was a situation with schultz and
weinberger they didn't do well when they
were around each other how often can you
remember seeing them not doing well
together many many times oh
there was a period there of um
i would say two years where their
relationship was so rocky so unpleasant
they didn't do well with each other
it made it hard it made it embarrassing
it's like
you going out
and with another couple one night and
all of a sudden they start fighting at
the
at the restaurant table
i mean you know after a while you get
embarrassed and you think you got i
shouldn't be here
it's unpleasant to watch when they
disagreed strongly and you said the
president didn't do anything about it
how were the disputes solved oh they
would go on or you know the meeting
would end or whatever
but i mean was there a difference of
substance where the president had to
make a decision on one side or the other
difference of substance is fine
it's totally legitimate in government
and there's a
obligation to play straight with the
president in fact one of the things i
i
points i hope to make in the book was
that people are too afraid
to either correct the president
or to be totally honest with what they
think
and that's a very big obligation that
you have
you have very few people have the kind
of substantive access to the president
that top people in the government have
and they have a solemn obligation
to go and tell the president straight
what they think what they know and the
president gets something wrong to
correct them but that was done very very
little
our guest is kenneth edelman and this is
the book
it's all about
symmetry
and there were five summits
with the soviets during ronald reagan's
presidency and you were present at three
of them the first three yep
i covered the
moscow summit for cbs news i was a
consultant for them and wrote about it
so i was kind of involved in that one
too
i want to ask you about the dedication
look and our audience will see it in
just a second
this book is dedicated to
in loving memory to donald r
murdock
who was he
he was a fellow that worked for rumsfeld
when i met him in the early 1970s
he was about our age
and he fought cancer
almost the whole time
that we knew him he had hepatitis he had
hodgkin's disease
he had you name it he had it and he had
such grit about him
and such determination that it was not
going to get him down in fact he had a
group
at the end of chicago where he entered
chemotherapy one time
and he had by far the worst condition
and he was the
longest living member of that class in
the university of chicago he just
outlived them all
and it finally got to him where grit
added 10 years to his life
so we lost him last year and i put a
dedication to him
that he couldn't have done it if he had
any quit in him at all
that came from he and i were
and our wives
who were close friends were out in
new mexico and we were with some
ranchers
we said how can you do this kind of
ranching it's a hard life
and the rancher turned to us and he says
can't do it at all
if you have any quit in you
and so i decided that was the perfect
kind of
summary of don murdock's life when did
you start writing your book
started writing about six months after i
left the government which was i left the
government december of 1987.
where did you write it
at home and at the office
when
what time during the day
you know
what you do when you write a book like
this i found
is that you have to just jot
things down constantly you keep a piece
of paper
in your pocket at all times
and when you get ideas you just put them
down
because otherwise
you're going to forget them and then
there's stories listen
i have had 10 stories popping my mind
since the book was published that i
should have
put in the book
how difficult was this
it's difficult
to try to take a subject like arms
control it's generally a turn off to
people
not get
bogged down in these mind-bending
acronyms numbers
categories no one really cares about
try to explain the basics
of u.s soviet relations
some about arms control in a correct way
but not in a boring way
and try to concentrate on people
the main reaction i have gotten from
friends who have read the book is it's
funny
it's human
it's moving
it's
i had lunch with someone yesterday who
knew firsthand about all the experience
he said at times he was it's hilarious
he was sitting there his wife would say
would call out what are you laughing
about he'd sit there in his chair and
just laugh and laugh
speaking of
what i assume you consider to be a
hilarious moment tell us the story
please about
the gorbachev reagan meeting in the
pantry
this was a strange episode
excuse me
we had
they had had a joint press conference in
geneva
it had two days together for the first
summit
and we were upstairs to say goodbye to
each other and everything like that
now the people were
waiters were passing out champagne there
was a little chit chat it was supposed
to be a 15 minute
goodbye
all of a sudden gorbachev says as we're
standing in a little circle gorbachev
says to reagan let me talk to you for
one minute alone
oregon says okay
the two of them go off into the pantry
upstairs in this international hall
leaving i'm sure the waiters and the
cooks amazed that the two most important
people in the world are suddenly in
their domain of the kitchen
and we're there
schultz myself and the whole u.s
allegation 10 of us or so
within a minute the two
[Music]
reagan and gorbachev come back
gorbachev says to reagan that was our
seventh time together
reagan says oh no this is our first
summit
brain says oh no this is our seventh
time together
reagan has a strange look on his face
and says
oh this was the 11th u.s soviet summit
since 1946 or something
and gorbachev
it's our seventh time
and reagan turns to all of us standing
there and says what do you think he
means
and i never
shy myself i said i don't know mr
president but maybe he means that this
was the seventh time the two of you
had time alone
reagan has a pain look on his face
he says is that what you mean
and gorbachev lights up he says yeah
that's exactly what i mean it's our
seventh time alone
reagan says
thinking of you know they were alone for
30 seconds didn't do anything
reagan says well it doesn't matter how
many times it is it matters what you get
done
and with that they toast and it's
goodbye
it took me a few months to figure out
what the hell was going on there
and then i pieced it together
here was gorbachev being a classic
western style politician
you could have a governor
or a senator or a congressman
go
and tell his people that seven meetings
with the president united states
which is much better than six or five
so we would consider abnormal behavior
for most mortals
normal for our politicians
is extremely abnormal for the
general secretary of the communist party
of the soviet union but that is exactly
what gorbachev wanted to do he wanted to
click up the number of meetings alone
with the president united states so he
could tell his friends and tell his
buddies and tell people back home
it's a revealing moment
because gorbachev is such an unusual
soviet leader
there's another moment that's way off
this subject
when
in reykjavik
ronald reagan's son
was present
looking different and acting different
than the rest that's in geneva
and by the way you write about three
summits in here that you were in
attendance and you write about the
moscow summit and what's the fifth
fifth was that u.n meeting that meeting
in december
what was that little incident well it
was strange
this was the first summit first u.s
soviet summit in seven and a half years
first time gorbachev and reagan had ever
either of them been in the summit first
time they would have met
spent the morning together we were
supposed to have lunch
with the president at 12 noon after the
first morning
we were at the chateau in geneva waiting
and they're
walking in about 11 30 or 4 to 12 is
ron
reagan jr
with some kind of balloon pants and some
kind of
real chic shirt
and looking real mod and cool
and
he had been and worn a credential
as a
journalist from playboy magazine
so reagan comes out of the about 12 15
he's about 15 minutes late president
comes out of his
motorcade in his limousine
and walks in the house
first person he mates is the son
the correspondent for playboy magazine
if anybody would have told me that the
first person
meet the president united states after
his first meeting with gorbachev
and the soviet leader is a correspondent
for playboy magazine i would have
doubted
anyway there he was and ron junior says
dad where were you you're late
and reagan looks at him you know it's
not an usual thing normal thing to tell
president you know you kept us waiting
you just wait for a present so reagan
says to well you know what happened we
have these translations
and it takes so much time he'll say
something
i'll say something in english will be
translated translated translated he said
it's just like the movies where you see
people talk talk talk talk talk in the
foreign films and on the bottom of the
screen flash that's fine
guest is ken edelman this is the book
the great universal embrace talking
about
symmetry and the subtitle there armed
summitry a skeptic's account
when you see a headline in the paper
that says you asked to go to a summit
with the soviet union what do you think
today
i think that a summit is
like cleopatra
it's awfully fun to be involved with but
it's quite treacherous
why
a lot can happen wrong in summits
we've seen that obviously in the munich
summit in 1938 we saw that in the vienna
summit of 1961
where john f kennedy
and
nikita khrushchev just didn't get along
which is fine but khrushchev walked out
thinking that kennedy was a wimp and
even worse yet
kennedy walked out thinking khrushchev
thought he was a wimp
and within a few months of that very
hasty summit ill-prepared summit
silly summit really
within a very few months of that you had
within two months you had the building
of the berlin wall that's still with us
you had the call up of reserves
for berlin and vietnam you had a buildup
in vietnam
and within a year you had the cuban
missile crisis
now what relationship those
have
to cruise chefs impression of kenny will
never know
but you have to think yourself
that they had a relationship because
khrushchev sized him up as just a wimp
it was just nothing a rich kid who just
got to be president and didn't have any
backbone to him he told us that kind of
stuff is very dangerous
when sure when chamberlain leaves a
munich summit
with hitler
goes back and tells his people here's a
man
that you can believe
you
get hitler's word you got something
that is such a bad misperception such a
bad
evaluation that it is extremely costly
uh it's been one of the worst size ups
in human history you told us earlier
that ronald reagan spent a lot of time
talking about arms
control
he had a lot of meetings with him on
did he look forward to summons he loved
them
absolutely love them
why
he understood better than any of us
that
first of all people
count
personalities count
you know these academics like myself and
others
tend to think historical forces the
times conditions the system
makes things happen
we're really people count and ronald
reagan knew that instinctively that if
you had a guy
like gorbachev it was different and it
was going to be different
and he was going to do different things
than the guy like fresh enough or a guy
like jeremy and co or any other guys
he also loved him because he understood
that summits are
more
like show business
than they are like boardroom meetings
so much
is the posturing
is the glitz
is the anticipation and then the
result as you frame it
it counted so much more that ronald
reagan in geneva that for the first time
they met
came out of the building
early
without a top coat on
met gorbachev coming up the stairs in a
big russian hat and a top coat
and then helped him inside that visual
meant so very much and was so very
important why is that does it seem like
ronald reagan who is what 20 years older
than gorbachev was far younger far more
vigorous
and he was greeting gorbachev
to come into what was going to be a
totally neutral summit it was an amazing
episode of showbiz
that carried an important message to
everybody around the world that ronald
reagan was really on top of things
and reagan understood that reagan was a
genius at these kind of things
one of the things that i want you to
tell us about
because you read about this during these
summits but you never get somebody who's
there to talk about how
the impact you write
i don't remember which summit it was
about being up in the middle of the
night
having your pen in hand being
responsible for the president's remarks
and bud mcfarland who is a national
security adviser at the time comes by
totally exhausted
and
tell tell
more about that instant that was in
geneva it was a
situation that we had been working very
very hard for these various days
and
we had a little office a white house
office
in
one of these places
i was there
drafting the president's remarks for the
next day of the joint appearance with
mikhail gorbachev
and i look up and there like some
ghosty
shakespearean figures bud mcfarland who
wasn't even staying
the place was he was staying in chateau
next to the president's chateau
and he comes in like hamlet's father or
something like that and a spirit from
the vastly deep
and they asked me what i'm doing and i
tell him they're doing this and he said
that's great
i said do you have any ideas how should
i do this no use your own judgment on
something like that
and i said is there anything else i can
do
to help you
he says yeah there really is i would
love it if you would go back on the
plane with all the journalists
briefed them after the summit
god knows i didn't know what i was
getting into with that but anyway i was
there i got the
remarks done
for the president next day shipped them
in the morning they were there for
reagan to see when they got up and for
bud mcfarland for george schultz to see
when they got up
everybody just thought they were fine
and there
two hours later with miquel gorbachev
and ronald reagan on the stage at the
international meeting place in geneva
president gets up and i just hear him
read my own words that are now six hours
old
usually the way government works you
would have such a process of grinding
and bumping and and such a group grope
on that kind of endeavor of presidential
remarks but here in summits for better
for worse you have a clear shot at the
man you list the four key questions that
you put in this speech but then the
sentence below that jumps out certainly
the president never expressed
the least interest in these questions
either then or subsequently so he got up
and read a speech included your four
questions in it didn't care about him we
sitting out here watching it
should have taken it all seriously or
should well that's one of the mysteries
of ronald reagan he could at times be so
seized with an issue
like sdi handle it beautifully
really do the right thing at other times
um
various issues like
criteria on soviet behavior you couldn't
care less
i guess i want to ask you whether all
that language around summits and
speeches and things like that based on
this story mean anything
most of it doesn't
one of the mysteries of this business
that we spend enormous time grafting
these communiques
for summits
days
previous administration spent months
doing it
they have a half-life of a few hours i
would say press we spend enormous time
drafting them
press grabs thousands of copies
hurriedly to file
for them
and then
[Music]
a few days later no one remembered the
first thing about them including those
in the government who drafted it it's
all vanishes that go to the goes to the
ash heap of history
you ever worry as you saw this process
that all this fatigue and late nights
and all that would lead to
mistakes yes
and that's why i say summits are like
leopatcher they're fun to be involved
with but they can be treacherous
because there is no guarantee
that a president is not going to make a
big mistake on this i think it's wrong
to have a summit where you put the
president up front to be the main arms
control negotiator i think it's crazy
i think we should have learned in the
versailles
situation with uh woodrow wilson you
don't have a president united states
your main negotiator
even before arms control
which is far more complicated far more
technical
why is that because every negotiator
who's going to do a good job
must have the ability to sound out feel
out check back home
and there is no checking back home when
the president united states is there he
is home
he's the headquarters
this is what the book looks like it's
called the great universal embrace armed
cemetery a skeptic's account by kenneth
edelman
former director of the united states
arms control and disarmament agency
and current
professor of shakespeare at georgetown
university columnist author
and
editor and editor of national editor of
washingtonian magazine thanks for
spending this time with us thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
bye
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
my
[Music]
that concludes this interview with
author kenneth edelman you can see this
program again later this evening at 11
30 pm eastern time next week our guest
on book notes will be the reverend ralph
abernathy he'll discuss his new
autobiography that's next sunday at 8pm
eastern time 5pm pacific
and after this short break join us for
our series capital agenda